OpenAI just released their latest model,
GPT 5.4, and this is seriously
impressive. So, in this video, I'm going
to go over all the crazy things that it
can do, plus we're going to go over its
specs, performance, and benchmarks
against other state-of-the-art models.
Let's jump right in. Thanks to HubSpot
for sponsoring this video. Let's start
this off with some demos. Now, note that
all the top models can already do simple
stuff like writing emails, writing
social media posts, answering simple
questions. So here I'm going to show you
some really challenging tests that very
few of the top models could get correct.
Now GPT 5.4 is available on chat GPT,
but what I'm going to show you first are
some examples in OpenAI's codeex. This
is basically like a coding agent that
can work on an entire project at once.
So how this works is it creates a new
folder on your computer and then it can
create and work on multiple files within
that folder. Especially if you're
building some really complex projects
that require multiple files, then this
is better than just using Chat GPT to
just vibe code one file. All right, so
here's our first prompt. Build a fully
interactive 3D digital twin of Earth
that allows users to zoom seamlessly
from outer space down to individual city
streets. Show a realistic planet Earth.
Use publicly available assets, models,
and layers if needed. Make sure it loads
efficiently on a regular web browser.
And then I'm going to set the reasoning
effort to extra high, which is the most
performant option. Let's click run. All
right. Now, here's what I got. First,
the first iteration was decent, but I
wanted to add more layers, so I prompted
it further. In orbital view, add toggle
for dynamic clouds and atmospheric
simulation. And then that looked kind of
awful, so I wrote use publicly available
realistic cloud or atmosphere layers.
Currently, they look too fake. Also add
a toggle for day and night at orbital
view. At night, I should be able to see
city lights of major populated areas.
And then afterwards, I still got some
display issues. So, I wrote, especially
in night mode, it seems there's a
translucent black layer that's dimming
everything. Remove this. And afterwards,
that's pretty much it. So, it's pretty
simple. Here is the entire folder with
all the files. Let's open up the HTML.
And here is what I got. How cool is
that? So, let's first turn off clouds
and atmosphere. And then let's also turn
off toggle spin. So here's what turning
off everything looks like. And then
let's turn on night view. Whoa, this is
really cool. So indeed, it's able to
convert this map into nighttime with
lights from all the major populated
areas. Now, here's the really cool
thing. Let me turn this back into day
view. And then we can zoom in directly
to New York like this. So let me click
on New York. And it zooms way in to New
York. And it renders a 3D map of New
York like this. How insane is that? I
can like drag this around. I can rotate
this. This is so cool. Now, let me hit
orbital view again to zoom out back to a
planet view. And then next, let's move
to Tokyo. And here it's zooming way into
Tokyo like this. Super cool. And indeed,
here we have a 3D map of Tokyo. So,
there you go. In just like three or four
prompts, I can build this fully
interactive planet Earth with different
layers. Plus, this can even zoom into
individual cities and render them in 3D.
This is an insanely powerful model. None
of the other top models could code this
up in just a few prompts. Next, let me
start a new project and let's see if it
can compose some really cool classical
music. Now, first, I need to get it to
actually make an interface for it to
compose music. So, I wrote make a piano
roll interface where I can drag and drop
notes on the timeline. Add play, pause,
and other settings, yada yada yada.
Again, I'm going to set this to extra
high and then press generate. All right,
so here's what I got. And it just
created a standard HTML of this
interface for me. Now, the next and the
most important part is I got it to show
a powerful expressive 32 bar piano opus
rich in complexity, capturing the final
performance of a master pianist. make it
sound amazing. So, here is what we got.
And that's pretty much it. It's only two
prompts. Let's open up the music folder
and this HTML file. And let's play this
Oh my god, that was actually beautiful.
I've tested this prompt with the other
top models out there like Gemini 3.1 as
well as GLM5, but this one by GPT 5.4 is
by far the most beautiful and coherent
piece I've heard so far. There's like so
much musical complexity into this. It's
not just simple chords. Everything is
actually very deep. Anyways, a super
impressive composition. All right,
here's another prompt that I test for
all the top models out there, which is,
how good is it at turning an image into
a 3D animated scene? So, I'm going to
upload this image and ask it to create a
beautiful 3D animated scene from this
image. Make it look as detailed and
accurate as possible. And again, I'm
going to set everything to extra high.
All right. So, afterwards, it proceeds
to generate this scene. But I do get an
error. So, I just pasted that error in.
And then the trees look kind of empty.
So, I just took a screenshot of the
scene and then asked it to make the
blossoms fuller. And then I prompted it
further. It still wasn't enough. Plus,
the petals look too dark. They should be
light pink. Afterwards, it fixed
everything. And here is what I got.
Again, this is by far the most accurate
3D render of this photo that I've seen
from any state-of-the-art model out
there. Both the trees and the pigota are
extremely detailed. It was even able to
add details of the rails, plus the walls
of the pigota. Plus, the top of the
pigota also looks fairly correct. Again,
this is just from a few prompts. The
details here are just way better than
anything generated with the other top
models out there, including Gemini 3.1
Pro. Super impressive. All right. Now,
those were some examples using codeex,
which is a coding agent powered by GPT.
But next, I'm also going to show you
some cool examples just using the native
chat GPT. So, if you are on one of the
paid plans, then you should already have
access to GPT 5.4. And over here is
where you can set the thinking to either
standard or extended, which makes it
think longer. And this is more suitable
for complex questions. So, here let's
try a ray tracing example. And let's
make this even harder. It's going to be
one sphere, one cube, and one pyramid.
All of them are metallic and reflective.
They are in a room with a mirror floor.
Add adjustable parameters such as
position, reflectivity, roughness, and
other material properties of the sphere.
Put everything in a standalone HTML
file. Make sure it loads efficiently on
a regular web browser. Now, in order to
preview this in a side window directly
in chat GBT, I also need to click over
here and enable this canvas mode. Let's
press run. All right. So, here's the
code that it gave me. And I first
prompted it to just allow me to change
the properties of the sphere and made
sure that everything works. And then
afterwards, I also prompted it to allow
me to change the properties and position
of the other shapes as well. And that's
pretty much it. In just two prompts,
here's the result. Here is our room
indeed with these three shapes. And
actually, let me download this so I can
view it in full screen. All right, so it
looks like this. And if I zoom in, you
can see that the sphere is reflected in
the cube which is reflected in the
sphere. So this is like infinitely
recursive reflections which is indeed
correct. Now if I look at over here you
can see again the pyramid shows a
reflection of the sphere with the
pyramid within its reflection. And you
can also see the pyramid reflected over
here. So everything is physically
correct. Let me zoom out a bit. And now
let me first change the position of the
sphere. So that works. And notice that
as I change the position, the
reflections of the sphere in the other
objects also change. Very nice. All
right. So that's the sphere. And then I
can also change the radius or basically
the size of the sphere. Very nice. Next,
let me also change the tint of this.
Let's make this blue. So that works. But
that's pretty ugly. So let's turn this
back to white. And then let's play with
the reflectivity. Let me decrease
reflectivity. So this setting works.
Very nice. And then let's try roughness.
Let's drag this all the way to one. So
that also works. Let's also decrease
metaleness all the way to zero, which
should make it look more opaque like
this. So that also works. Let me reset
the settings. And then finally for
emission. Let's see what that does. So
that basically makes it glow like this.
Very cool. And I can also set this to
chrome or gold or brushed like this.
Let's set this to chrome. All right. So
the sphere one works. Next, let's play
with the cube. So let's also adjust the
position of the cube. Very cool. So all
the position settings work. And then
let's play with the size a bit. That
also works. We can also rotate it. So
let's rotate the cube. That also works.
And then we can also change these
settings. All these settings just work.
Next, let me set this to gold. And then
finally, let's also ensure that the
pyramid works. So yes, the position
works. And then it even has this base
size adjuster. So, we can adjust the
size of the base of the pyramid. Very
cool. And notice that as I adjust this,
the reflections in the other shapes also
change with it. And then I can also
adjust the height of this. Very cool. As
well as the rotation. Next, we can also
play with the tint of this as well as
some other settings over here. And then
it also gives us some buttons to
optimize the performance as well as
resetting the view of everything. Very
cool. So in just one prompt, it's able
to render this scene, which is extremely
tricky. It has to figure out, you know,
how all these shapes reflect within each
other, plus also account for the colored
sidewalls. I mean, this is a very
physically tricky scene to render, but
GPT 5.4 just executed this correctly in
two prompts. You've probably heard of
Claude, but its new co-work feature
changes the baseline of what AI can do.
It doesn't just give you suggestions. It
actively works in the background,
accesses your files, and creates actual
deliverables. But knowing a tool is
powerful and actually getting it to
execute are two different things. That's
why HubSpot, who I'm partnering with,
created the Claude Co-work Stack. 12
advanced prompts to replace a week of
work. It's a free resource containing 12
advanced readytouse prompts designed to
replace a week of manual work. For
example, you can use their content
performance analyzer to drop in months
of raw analytics data, and Claude will
turn it into a presentation deck with
pattern recognition and strategic
recommendations. Or you can use this
meeting prep from calendar prompt, which
connects to your schedule and builds a
full briefing document for every meeting
before you even walk into the room. Or
here's one for turning messy transcripts
into strategy docs, generating entire
folders of SOPs at once, and building
competitive comparison matrices. If you
want to stop doing manual research and
start actually automating your work,
this stack is the exact starting point
you need. You can grab it for free using
the link in the description below. And
thanks to HubSpot for sponsoring this
video. All right. Now, because this is
multimodal, this can also analyze images
and different types of documents. Let's
see if it can identify cancer from a
medical scan. So, I'm going to upload
this medical image. And for each image,
there might be some tumors or lesions in
the image. In fact, I'm not even going
to tell it what this photo is. I'm going
to ask it what is this photo about? And
then if there are any lesions in the
photo, circle them. Again, I'm going to
turn on extended thinking and then press
run. All right. So, it thought for 2
minutes and 5 seconds. Let me expand its
thinking process so you can see what it
found. And here it's identifying and
annotating lesions. This image shows a
montage of axial CT chest slices, which
is correct. I'm spotting a few possible
lesions in the slices. And now it's
pulling up this Python tool to actually
circle this image. All right. So, that's
its thinking process. And finally, it
gives me this image to download. So here
is what it gave me and let me also pull
up the correct answer so you can
compare. All right. So on the left is
what chat GPT gave me and on the right
is the correct answer. Chat GPT was
close but it couldn't circle all the
lesions. So for example in this top
slide there should be a lesion here. For
the second slide it got it correct. For
the third slide it was only able to
identify this one but not this one. And
then for the fourth slide, it also got
it correct, but the circle wasn't really
aligned properly. So, it wasn't able to
identify all of them. But keep in mind,
this is a really hard test. The awesome
thing about GPT 5.4 is it's multimodal.
So, it can understand different types of
documents. Plus, this can also output
different types of documents, including
PDFs, docs, spreadsheets, slides, and
more. So, for example, I can upload
these three earnings reports from
Google, Nvidia, and Amazon. and plug it
into here and write, "You are a senior
Wall Street analyst. From these earnings
reports, make a consolidated PDF report
with financials, charts, growth
forecast, and recommendations." So, it
thought for 17 minutes, but afterwards,
it gave me this consolidated PDF report.
And here's what that looks like. Indeed,
this is quite a comprehensive and
detailed report outlining all the
metrics from the original documents. So,
here's profitability and cash
generation. And then here are company
specific pages. So here is Amazon and
then here's alphabet and then here is
Nvidia. And then finally it gives me
ranking and final recommendations.
Notice that the formatting of this is
kind of ugly. So for example it has gray
on black which is horrible. I do find
that GPT 5.4 isn't that good at design
and front end compared to other
state-of-the-art models. Now, instead of
just getting it to give me a PDF, I also
got it to turn the original documents
into a professional interactive
presentation. So, here is what it gave
me. Let's open this up. It was even able
to give me the logos of all the
companies. Again, it's pretty bad at
design. So, for example, it placed this
Amazon logo on this dark background,
which doesn't really look nice. You can
barely see the letters. But anyways,
here is slide one, slide two, slide
three, and so on. So, the design is not
great. I'm sure I can prompt this
further to make the design look more
polished. But from just one prompt, it's
already able to give me all these
slides. In fact, here are some official
demos from OpenAI with the same prompt
using 5.4 and 5.2. So, here they got it
to create a spreadsheet. And as you can
see, 5.4 is a lot more detailed. Here's
another example where you can also get
5.4 to create a document like this.
Again, the formatting of everything is
just a lot better than the previous GBT.
And then here's an example of a
presentation. All right, next. Let's see
if it can code up a pretty complex video
game just in chat GPT. So, for my
prompt, I asked it to make a 2D
platformer game of a futuristic Mecca
warrior against aliens. Make it look
amazing. Put everything in a standalone
HTML file. Include coin collection,
lives, ways to level up, and multiple
levels. And again, because I'm coding
something up, I need to turn on this
canvas feature so I can preview it in a
side window. Let's press run. All right,
so it coded everything up in just one
prompt. I didn't even need to prompt it
further. Let's press preview. So here's
what it looks like. In fact, let me
download this and view it in full
screen. And let's start playing this. So
let me shoot this guy. That works. And I
can also jump up and collect some coins.
Very nice. And once I collect enough
coins here, I can choose how to level
up. So, let's choose number one, plasma
core, and then let's continue playing
the game. And here's another enemy here.
What does that do? Oh my, I just got
shot by the damn thing. So, let me plan
how to kill this guy. So, after I killed
him next, let's choose this nano plating
to restore some of my HP, and then let's
continue the game. All right, so let me
just fast forward a bit. And after I
kill all the enemies, I can now enter
this portal, which takes me to the next
level. Really cool. And just like two
prompts, it can create this game for me
with different types of enemies with XP,
HP, and different ways to upgrade. GPT
5.4 just gets things done with very few
errors. The really cool thing about GPT,
especially if you use this in Codeex or
another Aentic coding framework, is you
can also link it to tools such as GPT
image 1.5, which is their best image
generator. So for example, here the user
got it to autonomously use the image
generator to create images of all these
different assets and then create this
park builder simulation from that. This
is quite a complex project with a ton of
different buildings and different guest
reactions, different metrics that you
need to be aware of. So it's really
impressive that GPT 5.4 was able to code
this up. Now, of course, the
state-of-the-art models are also really
good at doing deep research. So here's
an example of a really deep medical
question. Analyze the pathophysiology of
atherosclerosis.
Compare lipid lowering and
anti-inflammatory strategies. Evaluate
effects on plaque stabilization and
cardiovascular event reduction. Include
relevant tables and visualization. And
here is what I got. It used its Python
tool to plot out some really nice charts
for me. And then here it gives me an
introduction on what this is plus a
pathophysiology map. This is a very
comprehensive table with the correct
citations. And then afterwards it talks
about lipid lowering versus
anti-inflammatory strategies. And then
here it also gives me a very thorough
comparative table. This is extremely
thorough and it includes the relevant
citations. And then afterwards it gives
us this and then practical
interpretation and then bottom line. And
then it also proactively asks me if I
want to turn this into a polished PDF or
a slide deck or something else. All
right. Next, let's test how likely it is
to hallucinate. So, for my prompt, I'm
going to write, "I need to use the car
wash. The nearest one is 50 m from my
house. Should I just walk or drive
there?" And yes, I'm going to turn on
extended thinking. And it only thought
for 6 seconds, and it wrote, "Drive the
car there." It's only 50 m, so it'll
feel a bit silly, but a car wash usually
needs the car, which is correct. Note
that the previous version of GPT wasn't
even able to get this correct. Here's
another hallucination test. So again,
I'm going to turn on extended thinking
and I'm going to ask it, "What color are
cat feathers? White or gray?" And here
it only thought for a couple of seconds
and correctly answered that cats don't
have feathers. They have fur. And then I
tried to throw it off by saying, "I
don't think that's right. Are you sure?"
And it stood its ground and said, "Yes,
I'm sure. Real cats have fur, not
feathers." All right, so that sums up my
quick tests on GPT 5.4. After like a day
of testing, I would have to say it's
indeed one of the most performant and
intelligent models you can use right
now. All right, next let's go over where
and how to use this. So here they say
that 5.4 is available starting today to
plus team and pro users in chat GPT. So
yes, unfortunately you do need to have a
paid plan to access 5.4 for now. This is
not available on the free plan. But if
you do have a paid plan, then in this
model dropdown you can select 5.4. 4
over here. The awesome thing is for
developers, 5.4 is already available via
API. Plus, it's already available in
codecs as I've shown you earlier in this
video. Next, let's go over some specs of
this. So, one of the best features of
this is GPT 5.4, at least if you use it
in codeex, supports a 1 million token
context window. This is how much
information you can fit into your prompt
at once. And 1 million is one of the
largest in the industry. This is like
roughly 700,000 words or 300,000 lines
of code. Note that other competitors
like Anthropics Claude or GLM do not
have such a high context window. Now,
it's important to note that this 1
million context window is only in
codeex. If you use GPT 5.4 in chat GPT,
it's a lot lower. It's only up to 400K.
Now, here they call 5.4 their most
capable and efficient Frontier model for
professional work. This model is super
flexible. It can work across tools,
software environments, and professional
tasks involving spreadsheets,
presentations, and documents. In fact,
one of the first charts that they share
is this GDP val benchmark for knowledge
work tasks. This tests an AI on
knowledge work spanning 44 occupations
from the top nine industries
contributing to the US GDP. So, this
includes things like making sales
presentations, accounting spreadsheets,
urgent care schedules, manufacturing
diagrams, or short videos. And as you
can see here, GPT 5.4 outperforms the
previous 5.2 by a huge margin. And then
here they're basically looking at the
win rate compared with an industry
expert human. The crazy thing is GPT 5.4
beats the human 70% of the time. So, you
know, for those of you who are worried
that AI will take your job, well, you
should be because I mean, this graph is
quite alarming, especially if your job
involves these knowledge work tasks.
Here they say that GPT 5.4 is also
incredibly good at computer use
capabilities. In other words, just using
your computer autonomously. So here on
this OSWorld verified benchmark which
tests a model's ability to navigate a
desktop environment through screenshots
and keyboard and mouse actions. You can
see that the performance and accuracy of
GPT 5.4 is much higher than GPT 5.2.
Plus it also uses fewer tool yields. So
it's more efficient and it doesn't waste
as many tokens. Here's an example where
if you feed it this live stream of your
desktop, GPT 5.4 four is able to analyze
this and help you write an email. It's
able to analyze and know where to type
the recipient and the subject. Or here's
another example where you can just feed
it this massive JSON file which lists a
ton of invoices and it can autonomously
fill out all this information into these
forms on the left. Now, for MMU Pro,
which tests an AI models visual
understanding and reasoning
capabilities, GPT 5.4 4 only showed a
really small improvement over the
previous 5.2. So it's only like less
than 2%. Now for coding, OpenAI chose to
use SWEBench Pro instead of SWEBench
verified which is the main benchmark
that's used by Anthropic. So I'm sure
you know each AI lab is cherrypicking
the benchmarks where their models
perform the best. So anyways, here is
SWEBench Pro and as you can see GPT 5.4
is not only better than the previous
models but also faster. Here's another
interesting benchmark called the Tao
Square Bench Telecom. And this basically
tests an AI's ability to handle customer
service tasks. So, it simulates a real
world technical support scenario where
the agent has to solve incoming
problems. And as you can see, GPT 5.4 is
significantly better than the previous
versions. And then here is another
benchmark called browse comp, which
tests how good an AI is at browsing the
web and retrieving information. And
again, 5.4 4 is better than the previous
versions. Now, these are just some of
their self-reported benchmarks. So,
let's also look at some independent
evaluators. So, if you look at this
leaderboard by Artificial Analysis, GPT
5.4 is actually tied for the number one
spot with Gemini 3.1 Pro. However, in
terms of speed, it is a bit slower than
Gemini 3.1, and that's the vibe I got as
well. I feel like for some of the time,
it's just overthinking. It just takes
way too long to think, even though the
prompt isn't that challenging. And then
in terms of price, it is higher than
Gemini 3.1 Pro, but still way cheaper
than Opus 4.6, which is like almost
double the cost. Couple of other
noteworthy metrics from the site is this
crit pt benchmark, which test an AI's
ability to solve some really complex
research level physics problems. And as
you can see, GPT 5.4 extra high is
currently number one. And in addition to
physics, GPT 5.4 is also incredibly good
at math. So here is the Frontier Math
benchmark, which tests an AI models
ability to solve some really challenging
math problems. And as you can see, GPT
5.4 Pro is currently ranked number one.
It got 37.5%
of the questions correct, much better
than Claude Opus as well as Gemini. So
if you need an AI model that's good at
solving math or physics problems,
currently 5.4 4 is the best one to use.
However, that being said, GPT 5.4 extra
high also has an insanely high
hallucination rate. So, you can see that
GPT 5.4 extra high is over here. Notice
that the higher the score, the more
often it makes stuff up. Now, this
doesn't mean it hallucinates 89% of the
time. This means that it got 89% of the
questions from this benchmark wrong.
But, as you can see, it's way higher
than the previous versions, like 5.3 or
5.2. 2 or even Opus 4.6. So if you're
working with an AI model and you need to
ensure that its responses are factually
correct, 5.4 would not be the best
option to use. It's best to use
something like GLM5. So that's one
independent benchmark from artificial
analysis. But if you look at another
leaderboard from LM Arena, surprisingly,
GPT 5.4 High is only ranked number
seven, even below 5.2 and Gemini 3.
Here's another independent leaderboard
called LiveBench by Abacus AI. And here
you can see that GPT 5.4 with extra high
thinking is indeed ranked number one.
It's especially impressive in terms of
reasoning, agentic coding, mathematics,
and data analysis. I tried also looking
at the official SweetBench leaderboard,
but it doesn't look like they've added
GPT 5.4 here yet. Now, GPT 5.4 4 Pro
extra high also does insanely well on
this Arc AGI 2 benchmark, but it's still
beat by Gemini, which is the green
triangle. For your information, this Arc
AGI benchmark is very important. Now, on
the surface, this tests how good an AI
model is at solving these visual
puzzles. It's first given a question
answer pair and then another question,
and it needs to apply the same pattern.
For example, here we need to color these
gray blobs according to how many holes
it has. Now, for a human, it's pretty
easy to deduce and solve this. But for
an AI, it's actually really hard. You
can see like even some of the frontier
models score really badly on this
benchmark. And that's because an AI
model can't actually learn new things
after training. Its model weights and
parameters are fixed. So here, it's
testing if the AI model can take in new
information such as this new pattern,
and also apply it in its response. It's
testing how good an AI model is at
learning new things even though
technically it can't learn. And here you
can see that GPT 5.4 does pretty good,
though it's still slightly beat by
Gemini. Next, we also have this Vibe
Code Bench, which of course tests how
good an AI model is at vibe coding. And
GPT 5.4 is currently ranked number one,
even above Opus 4.6 and Gemini 3.1 Pro.
And as I've showed you from some of my
demos, I also feel that it's really good
at vibe coding. Anyways, that sums up my
review of GPT 5.4. It's definitely one
of the most performant and intelligent
models you can use right now, but
honestly, it's pretty close to the other
top models like Gemini 3.1 and Opus 4.6.
Each model has a unique vibe to it. So,
it really depends on which one you
personally prefer. Let me know in the
comments what you think of this, and if
you've had a chance to play around with
5.4, what other cool or impressive
things were you able to get it to do? As
always, I will be on the lookout for the
top AI news and tools to share with you.
So, if you enjoyed this video, remember
to like, share, subscribe, and stay
tuned for more content. Also, there's
just so much happening in the world of
AI every week, I can't possibly cover
everything on my YouTube channel. So, to
really stay up to date with all that's
going on in AI, be sure to subscribe to
my free weekly newsletter. The link to
that will be in the description below.
Thanks for watching and I'll see you in
the next one.